hey youtubers is Charlie day three of
shaky-cam VidCon so I have a funny
Deadpool clip him just roasting the [ __ ]
out of the x-men in some cool Deadpool 2
News
so I'm gonna play the clip make sure you
watch the end for the Deadpool stuff and
then I'll talk about the movie like this
before
it took him present the world needs the
x-men I'm not here students pick up T if
I'm going to teach your kid something
I'm going to teach them how to fight
follow me
Joe huh I'm not afraid of them I need oh
he's my father
what never my mom like yeah I know
not all of us can control our powers
then don't
apocalypse means to destroy this world
it's all of us against a god and the
most powerful beings on earth
you
forget everything you think you know
none of that matter you're not students
anymore
not taking anything from them you're
excellent
well you've been busy we had a little
help
oh hi Japan
Deadpool here surprised I just wanted to
share with you my two cents on five
things you may have missed in the x-men
apocalypse trailer I know what you're
thinking an after credit scene for a
trailer I thought they only did that for
movies right well not everyone makes to
the end of Fox movies so now we're doing
it after trailers number one this movie
is set in the 80s and apparently
apocalypse kicks professor X's ass for
forgetting to wake him up before he go
go number two major plot twist when
Quicksilver discloses to mystique that
magneto is his father
and he's a fan of Canadian supergroup
Rush so many plot twists number three
fun fat psylocke is a hot-looking girl
using a super-powered katana and I'm a
horrible looking man using a katana
twinsies number four looks like they're
introducing a Japanese mutant with Ginsu
knives coming out of his hands let's see
how that goes number five this wasn't
really in the trailer but important for
you to know the newest addition to the
super dysfunctional x-men family me
Deadpool comes out in Japan on June 1st
I've definitely never felt power like
this before so be there June 1st
what the hell is going on so there are a
couple Easter eggs in there but it's
mostly an advertisement for Deadpool
when they were getting ready to release
it in Japan so they do release
region-specific content if they feel
like people don't totally understand who
the character is or he's not as popular
in certain parts of the world but I feel
like he's pretty popular everywhere just
based on the box office except for China
because it was banned in China I'm sure
there are plenty people in China that
found other ways to watch the movie so
one there's a wham joke in there I mean
he's making a bunch of 80s jokes
the candidate joke is just because Ryan
Reynolds is Canadian Deadpool is also
Canadian like the character himself is
Canadian as is Wolverines character even
though he isn't making fun of him for
being Canadian
usually when Deadpool makes jokes about
Wolverine or Hugh Jackman he makes
Canadian jokes it's just a good example
of Deadpool's marketing and if you
wonder why they didn't do this when they
originally released x-men apocalypse
because it might you know might have
been a little bit more fun I think it's
because they felt like x-men epochal
such a serious film they didn't want to
cloudy it up or confuse people make them
think the Deadpool was going to be in it
when he's not even though I do expect
him to be in the next x-force film but I
do feel like even if Deadpool isn't
going to be in an x-men film any of
their marketing for any of their movies
would benefit from his presence but you
would be surprised the number of people
that are confused by stuff like this
like they would see Deadpool and they
just assume that he's in the movie so
Deadpool news though there's actually
really exciting Deadpool stuff that's
been happening Simon Kinberg who's one
of the big producers on Deadpool in law
these x-men films said that they'll be
shooting Deadpool - really early next
year like January early February next
year meaning that they'll probably be
able to release that later in 2017 if
they can get the edit out fast enough
you'd be surprised at how fast they can
turn films around when they're not too
big like x-men apocalypse has a ton of
characters it's a huge film Deadpool is
a little more self contained so it
doesn't take them quite as long to get
it out
Deadpool - though I will start making
more videos for that later this year
they start to announce stuff now we
already know cables going to be in it
but we don't know about any of the other
secondary characters so once they do
I'll do some more videos for that but
you I mean you can look at the psylocke
joke like he's like oh we both use
katanas we're like peas in a pod but you
could look at this as him subtly hinting
that psylocke might appear in a Deadpool
crossover but I feel like that would be
x-force just because she's such a big
part of x-force in the comics and Olivia
Munn was so underutilized in x-men
apocalypse that I feel like they could
use x-force to really build that
character out because she's actually
pretty interesting character in the
comics but let me know who you want to
see in Deadpool - besides cable that is
and let me know what kind of marketing
stuff you want to see from the film like
what kind of trailers you want to see
them do like Deadpool did a lot of
parody trailers when that film came out
like you did the prostate exam that was
actually pretty meta but what's going to
happen later today is there's been
rumors about Fox Marvel stuff happening
behind the scenes it's very preliminary
but I'll do a video for it kind of
explaining what a Marvel Fox
spider-man sharing deal might look like
Sony style like Marvel's Sony sharing
the spider-man character-building films
together
I don't think Fox and marvel's
arrangement would go that deep just
because Fox already has a you know
marginally successful x-men film
universe I don't think they're quite as
concerned as Sony was about building
their film universe out but I do think
that it
point you will see x-men characters
crossover with Marvel characters so I'll
do a video for that later today so be
sure to subscribe to get that
and even though VidCon is happening
right now I'll be home tomorrow because
sunday will be all about Game of Thrones
finale stuff I'll be doing a bonus video
then I'll do my finale video there'll be
all kinds of craziness and I'll be doing
a new round of the giveaway too so get
hype while you guys wait for that video
to post you can click over here on the
side to learn all about flash rebirth
number one the new god speed flash
filling and you can click here for my
Game of Thrones finale trailer for
tomorrow thank you so much thank you so
much CIM thank you so much for watching
and if you guys see me at a big con
today feel free to say hi
you